So here's a third useful fact,
that I probably should have put
first now that I write it down.
And that is the idea that, if we start
off with sum Q function, Q1, and we
run k steps of value iteration, in other
words we apply the Bellman operator k
times, that the k step Bellman
operator is a contraction mapping.
And the index of contraction is like
gamma to the k which is a much,
much smaller number.
So running k steps of value iteration
actually pushes your value functions
much closer together than let's say,
a single step value iteration.
Which is really what you'd expect.
>> That is,
although that's even better, right,
because it's not just like linear.
>> It's not like linear.
>> Right, it's like gamma squared,
gamma cubed, gamma to the third,
gamma to the k.
>> Right, and that is the index of
contraction so we run ten steps of value
iteration, that's like running one
step of ten step value iteration.
So again, it's not super surprising but
what's nice about it is
it gives us a way of quantifying
how long we run value iteration and
connecting it with how close you are to
optimal after you've run that far.
And so, this kind of fact is underlying
these other things that I wrote number
one and number two which is probably why
I should have set the third one first.
>> That's okay, we can fix it in post.